my pop
[Music]
did you expect Guillermo del Toro's
Pinocchio to be so intense this
adaptation hits you hard from the
beginning so without further Ado let's
discuss all the details that made this
version far darker than Disney's
somebody understood how dark it felt to
be a child
number one this is not Disney's Geppetto
we wanted the better to be really really
full of edges the 1940 animated movie
depicts Geppetto as a lonely puppet
maker who simply makes Pinocchio as a
companion but Guillermo del Toro fills
in a backstory that is so much darker
what is this what kind of sorcery here
we find out that he had a real Flesh and
Blood Sun before Pinocchio but that his
passing turned Geppetto to drink one
night in a blind rage he carves
Pinocchio out of the pine tree that grew
over his son's grave before waking up
hungover with no idea what he'd done
Guillermo del Toro explained that his
backstory touches on what the movie is
ultimately about which is the
relationship between flawed fathers and
flawed Sons either you make the movie
the right way or is almost as good not
to make it number two if you've seen the
movie you know the setting plays a huge
role Guillermo del Toro's Pinocchio
takes place in 1930s Italy during the
rise of fascism though as he pointed out
which all happens by the way on the
periphery or off-screen Guillermo del
Toro has said if I can avoid it I refuse
to have a proper war scene but added
that in the making of this movie he felt
that the Dynamics of the ghostly
corrosive parental power that flashes
and makes sense over certain Souls it
needs to be there Guillermo del Toro
especially wanted to explore this theme
through the characters of podesta and
his son whose relationship has become
strained by podesta's military career
and high expectations
you will know what it is to truly serve
the Fatherland number three have you
noticed the similarities between
Pinocchio and Frankenstein Guillermo del
Toro has as he pointed out both stories
are about a father who creates a son
sort of in a haphazard manner before
sending him into the world without any
real assistance adding and I felt like
that as a kid but that isn't the only
parallel when it came to the moment
where Geppetto puts Pinocchio together
Guillermo del Toro has said we wanted to
make the the scene almost feel like
Frankenstein's lab all of the thunder
and lightning as well as the harsh
movements like branches breaking are
meant to evoke in almost
frankenstein-like feel which Guillermo
del Toro felt added to the sense of
trauma about the birth it's me I came to
church
number four how would you respond to
finding this in your attic Pinocchio
isn't entirely in control of his body
when he's first brought to life so when
Geppetto first meets him Pinocchio moves
in such a way that he looks like a
spider Pinocchio's design is generally
much darker in Guillermo del Toro's
version than it was in the original
Disney movie taking plenty of
inspiration from the illustrations of
Chris Grimley for the 2002 reprint of
Carlo collodi's novel The Adventures of
Pinocchio Guillermo del Toro felt that
Chris grimley's illustrations embodies
and unruliness and in Elemental nature
before going on to say it's really the
key to the whole thing it's okay to be a
monster we are all monsters at the end
of the day number five how well do you
remember Disney's version of the Blue
Fairy there the Blue Fairy had a very
sweet and almost Snow White like design
about her in Guillermo del Toro's
version however Pinocchio is brought to
life by a Wood Sprite instead who looks
a little different when discussing where
he got his inspiration Del Toro added
that death and life on Pinocchio looked
like Mexican carvings he explains that
plenty of colonial paintings depict
archangels and seraphim with multiple
eyes across the wings and that Legend
has it it that one eye closes every time
a soul passes number six how shocking
was it to see Pinocchio Die For the
First Time Pinocchio visits the
underworld and speaks with death several
times throughout the film you cannot
truly truly die Guillermo del Toro has
said that he intended for death to serve
as the most motherly figure in
Pinocchio's life pointing out that
there's something very nurturing in the
way that death slowly guides Pinocchio
toward making the right decision Del
Toro went on to explain that he sees a
certain Beauty in the idea of death
especially as he gets older it's
beautiful because if
something doesn't end they've never be
gone number seven this movie doesn't
include the most frightening moment from
the Disney version help help somebody
help and yet what it replaces it with is
so much darker instead of being taken to
Pleasure Island Guillermo del Toro's
version sees Pinocchio recruited into
the village military Camp because the
fascist official in the town thinks if
this puppet cannot die and you will be
the perfect Soldier fun and games have
been replaced with drills and paintball
and rather than being turned into
donkeys these children are being turned
into soldiers Guillermo del Toro
admitted in an interview with Vanity
Fair that all this is very intense but
explained for me this is for both
children and adults that talk to each
other it tackles very deep ideas about
what makes us human number eight the
song is a far cry from When You Wish
Upon a Star I thought it would be
interesting to start the movie with
characters that sing much of the music
for Guillermo del Toro's Pinocchio was
performed using wind instruments for
more chilling effect but by far the most
haunting song would have to be ciao Papa
performed by Gregory Mann Del Toro
described it as both the most moving
song in the film and the most important
song before going on to explain that it
talks about longing it talks about the
loss of a father and the loss of a son
composer Alexander Des flat spoke about
how he wanted ciao Papa to stand out as
its own unique moment stating I think
the lyrics say everything number nine
Pinocchio's relationship with Geppetto
is a bit more complicated this time
Guillermo del Toro described Geppetto by
saying he's a father that's very
concerned with the way everybody looks
at him and how Pinocchio makes him look
no no please it's a purpose this
combined with Pinocchio's more unruly
Behavior means that there's a lot more
conflict between them than there was in
the Disney animated classic you tell him
whom I love him and I won't be a burden
anymore but also over the course of the
story the one that one translation in
this Pinocchio is this guy Guillermo del
Toro says that this time around the
battle learns to be a real father as
opposed to pinocular learning to be a
real boy number 10. this theme of
Fathers and Sons appears in ways you may
not have noticed one scene in Guillermo
del Toro's version has Pinocchio being
forced to perform for Benito Mussolini
which ends with the puppet publicly
insulting him when asked why he chose to
include this scene Del Toro went on to
explain how he wanted to explore the
theme of Fathers and Sons in multiple
ways and that Mussolini represents a
more harmful version of fatherhood on
the other hand the film also includes
references to God and Jesus with
Pinocchio playing the role of surrogate
imperfect Messiah resurrecting and dying
for those that he loves number 11.
there's value and Disobedience although
Guillermo del Toro grew up loving Walt
Disney's version of Pinocchio he
admitted that there was one part of the
movie that always bugged him idea of
obedience and being something you're not
in order to be accepted he admitted that
one of his own personal challenges when
he set out to write the film was to see
can I make a Pinocchio that celebrates
Disobedience because of this breaking
the rules actually comes in handy a few
times throughout the film like when
Pinocchio has to escape from the belly
of the terrible Dogfish by lying number
12. beware the terrible Dogfish if you
think you know the story of Pinocchio
being that he eventually finds Geppetto
in the belly of a giant whale that was
actually a change made for the Disney
version for Guillermo del Toro's version
I'm going back to the original book and
bringing back the terrible Dogfish Carlo
collodi's novel described the Beast as
being larger than a five-story building
what are your thoughts on this darker
adaptation of Pinocchio do you think
they were an improvement or do you still
prefer the Disney version make sure to
let us know down in the comments and
don't forget to like And subscribe to
the things